[DRUMROLL]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
(SINGING) Do we shock
you, make you ill at ease?
Do we offend your
tender sensibilities?
There's no norm we
won't transgress.
Look, there's a man and
he's wearing a dress.
Yeah.
I mean, I've literally seen
every season of "Drag Race,"
so.
(SINGING) Do we scare you?
Are you too refined?
(SINGING) I'm into
boys and girls.
(SINGING) Does just
blow your mind?
All the girls get
thanked and tipped.
Us, we just like to get
spanked and whipped.
Wonder if the
meatloaf's any good.
[MUSIC CONTINUES]
(SINGING) Does that shock you?
We hope it shocks you
because we're clearly putting
a lot of effort into it.
What do you think about this?
I've got a tattoo.
That's cool.
Cool.
(SINGING) What do
you think about that?
I've experienced an
orgasm, a female one.
(SINGING) What do
you think about--
[MUSIC CONTINUES]
Does that shock you?
We hope it shocks you.
Because we're really
putting a lot of effort.
Really putting a lot of effort.
Really putting a lot of effort,
really putting a lot of effort,
really putting a lot
of effort into it.